now I must take you from the realm of
rationality and moral agency to the
realm of unreason and slavery and into
the mindset of the slaves of Allah and
the Islamic theology that underlies the
genocidal axis and the will to genocide
in the Middle East and in the Islamic
World in general today uh Eric noted
that there were 880,000 Jews in Egypt in
1933 and there have been Jewish
communities all over the Middle East
from time immemorial up until
1948 when those communities were
decimated and the Jews were expelled
from them on MOS uh such that there is
only for example one Jew left in
Afghanistan out of several thousand
there uh 100 years ago uh there were
churches and Christians from time in
Memorial from long before Islam uh in
the Middle East as well uh Egypt for
example was a 19 9% Christian country at
the time of the Islamic conquest in the
7th century and it uh is now about 10 to
15% Christian but one of the things that
has been happening recently as Eric also
noted is that the Brotherhood is burning
churches and destroying Christian
communities wholesale now this is also
something that is not solely limited to
the Brotherhood but is carried out by
other Islamic groups and has been going
on for longer than just the upheaval
that has been engulfing Egypt ever since
the Brotherhood first took power in 2011
and then was removed from Power
subsequently by the
military what we see for example in as
far back as 2006 is the melite Greek
cathol melite Greek Catholic patriarch
Gregory III saying that there was a
concerted effort a an organized effort
to expel all the Christians from the
Middle
East and in the seven years since then
that effort has only gained strength and
has expanded in its scope but it becomes
then a question why is this happening
now why is it that Jews lived in the
Muslim world and under Muslim
rule up until 1948 and were not forcibly
expelled why is it that Christians lived
in the Muslim world and under Muslim
rule up until quite recently but now
there is this concerted effort that the
meite Greek Catholic patriarch referred
to to drive them out and churches are
being burned and so on now most analysts
particularly in Washington would answer
that question by saying well see it's
because Islam is a religion of peace and
these Muslim Brotherhood operatives and
the others like them are twisting and
hijacking its peaceful teachings to
create this
virent form of Islam that can't abide
the other within its presence and is
driving them out but if we can just get
the real true Muslims in there then
everything will be okay and
unfortunately this is a position that
prevails among both parties in
Washington among all mainstream analysts
and everyone pretty much takes it for
granted the only problem with it is that
it is a wholly and entirely
false there is no truth to the idea that
there is some group of Muslims that we
can put in power or support in their
efforts to gain power in the Middle East
that will stop this from happening and
the reasons for that lie within Islamic
theology so if you could open your
qurans now we're going to look at a few
passages one of them is chapter 9: 29
which says fight against those who do
not obey Allah and his messenger and do
not forbid what he has forbidden even if
they are of the people of the book that
is the Jews and the Christians primarily
until they pay the gizia which is a tax
with willing submission and feel
themselves subdued that is the
foundation of what I'm sure you have
heard of is dimude the
institutionalized discrimination and
harassment of Jews and Christians in the
Islamic State but the word dimma means
protection and the demies are protected
people now you remember the Mafia you
know you pay protection to the mafia and
they don't smash your store window you
pay protection to the Muslim government
and you have the right to live and to
practice your religion to live as a Jew
or Christian but you still have to pay
you pay the tax and you were denied
basic rights so that in your humiliated
and subjugated status you are always
reminded every day that you have
rejected muhammmad rejected Islam
rejected the truth Hellfire awaits you
and deprivation and suffering in this
world as well and that the Muslims have
the responsibility to
enforce now the dimma the system of
subjugation of the Jews and Christians
is the law of Islam it's
Sharia but it has not been enforced in
the Islamic world since the
1850s the Ottoman Empire the last
Islamic empire abolished the dimma in
1856 under pressure from the
West Egypt abolished it around the same
time also under pressure from the west
and the Arab nationalist governments
that came to power in the middle part of
the 20th century and ruled most of the
Middle East up until quite recently
Nasser saddat and Mubarak in Egypt Ben
Ali in Tunisia borba before him uh the
assads in Syria Saddam Hussein in Iraq
these were not these were Muslims but
they were aside from the assads but they
were not ruling According to Islamic law
they were ruling according to the batist
philosophy of Arab nationalism which was
a race-based
socialist ideology derived from Western
European fascism with a mixture of uh
other ideas derived from the uh Soviet
Union and socialist Notions that were
going around Europe at the time and of
course are stronger than ever in some
quarters
and they essentially granted equal
rights to the non-muslim
minorities up until the founding of the
state of Israel at the time of the
founding of the state of Israel then
suddenly the Jews are all expelled from
these Middle Eastern countries although
the Christians continued to live in
relative peace up until recently what
happened to both communities is the same
they were set upon
by elements within those countries that
even though they were ruled by the Arab
nationalists the we're talking about
Muslim countries and there was still a
strong undercurrent within all of these
nations for the re-imposition of Islamic
law and the idea that the governments
that they were living under had no
legitimacy because they did not obey
Islamic law and this is why the Muslim
Brotherhood was outlawed in Egypt by
those Arab nationalist governments
because they had brought popular support
since their political philosophy was
based in Islamic law and so Muslims saw
it as part of their Islamic identity and
Islamic responsibility to be aligned
with groups like the Brotherhood but the
Arab nationalist regimes saw their enemy
and recognized their enemy when they saw
him and so they outlawed the uh these
groups the problem is that at the same
time they had to offer carrots as well
as sticks to these groups because they
did enjoy so much popular support and so
the in other words the elements of
Islamic law that victimize Jews and
Christians remained a strong cultural
subcurvata
in Islamic law if you rebel against the
the rule of the Muslims if you reject
the overlordship of the Muslims if you
say I don't want to live as a subjugated
second class citizen having to step off
the sidewalk when the Muslims are
passing and not being able to get a good
job because only Muslims can have
authority over other Muslims and so I
have to have the most menial job in
society where I don't have authority
over any Muslim uh I I I have to live if
all these all these all this kind of
Institution IED
harassment if he reject it then the
protection is revoked just like if you
don't pay the mafia they will break your
windows so when Israel was founded it
was widely assumed in the Islamic world
that the Jews are at war with Islam now
they're not accepting the rule of the
Muslims they're not accepting the
overlordship of the Muslims they are at
war with Islam and their lives are
forfeit and so they were killed they
were massacred they were expelled from
those
countries now the same thing is
happening now with the Christians the
Muslim Brotherhood took power in Egypt
and they announced their intention to
impose Islamic law in Egypt and they
adopted a constitution that said just
that Islamic law mandates the
subjugation of the Christians but the
Christians have been living in this Arab
nationalist regime for 50 years and had
not suffered under the dimma since the
1850s the Christians said well no we're
not going to accept that and there were
Coptic leaders who said we will resist
the imposition of the dimma to the point
of martyrdom when you're talking about
10 to 15% of the society that's saying
we're going to plunge this country into
Civil War if you enforce Islamic law
upon
us and so the Muslim Brotherhood saw
that and of course the Muslim
Brotherhood they're by the book Muslims
they read the Quran they understand
Islamic law they don't they don't have
to bother with all the deceptive
nonsense that we have blanketing the
public discourse in the United States
about how it's really a religion of
peace and they don't believe any of
these things and so the Muslim
Brotherhood leaders said okay you will
not accept the dimma you will not take
the contract of protection then you have
no protection and the churches are being
burned and the Christians are being
killed and it's exactly the same
phenomenon happening for exactly the
same
reason when the contract of protection
is
revoked the Dem lives are forfeit and
the contract of protection is revoked if
they refuse to accept the dimma Hamas in
Gaza has said when they consolidate
their power which means when they take
over Judea and Samaria as well then they
will impose the dimma over the remaining
Christians there the Syrian jihadis have
said the same thing this is part of
Islamic law it has never been reformed
it has never been rejected and there is
no school of Islamic Juris Prudence that
does not teach this institutionalized
discrimination
so when the Christians reject it their
lives are forfeit and this is exactly
what we are seeing now they are kufar
har infidels at war with Islam and this
is a theological designation within
Islamic law that makes their their blood
Halal which means their blood is
acceptable to be shed and indeed the
Muslims have the responsibility to wage
war against such people and to kill such
people wherever possible and so
so one of the biggest failures of the
Obama
Administration is his betrayal of the
Christians in Egypt and all across the
Middle East and his failure his refusal
to speak
out but we also have to acknowledge that
one of the biggest failures of the
Republican party is its failure to hold
Obama's feet to the fire and demand that
he make American Aid to those Nations
contingent upon their treatment of
religious
minorities one of the biggest failures
of the Republican party in 2012 and of
Mitt Romney in that third debate the
foreign policy debate where he should
have delineated his position from
Obama's most
starkly was that all he could say was me
too and Obama said we have to arm the
rebels in Syria and Romney said oh yes
we do indeed well then what was the
point I was watching that and you know
this is I'm sorry this is the only issue
I care about and I thought I don't have
any reason to vote for either one of
those guys because the rebels in Syria
are jihadis who are going to impose
Islamic law in Syria they will be
enemies of the United States no matter
how many billions of dollars we give
them and how many roads and hospitals
and and everything else that we build
schools that we build and they're going
to murder the non-muslims the alawites
as well as the Christians in Syria
wholesale and of course now we're giving
them
weapons and it seems as if for whatever
combination of reasons there are very
few people and I'm very proud and
honored that to stand in the room I see
Congressman goer over here and of course
Congressman Franks on the on the
deis there are people in the Republican
Party who understand this issue
I strongly urge that everyone who has
access to politicians who are running
for office or who are contemplating
running for office or who are in office
now to try to impress upon them the
gravity of this situation and the
reality of the fact that there is no uh
moderate Muslim group or peaceful Muslim
group or self-professed moderate Muslim
group that we can throw our support
behind that is not going to go along
with this same program and we're kidding
ourselves if we think otherwise these
are elements of Islamic law that no sect
of Islam rejects not a
one and it is a scandal of extraordinary
proportions that we are Aid as the
United States of America we are aiding
and abetting the genocide of these
people but we are when we give weapons
to the Syrian rebels and this has to be
a campaign issue in 14 and in 16 or it's
only going to get worse
people are afraid I think in the
Republican party to take this stance and
to say that uh American Aid would be
contingent upon equal rights for the
religious minorities in those countries
because they think that it would be [__]
as racist and bigoted and islamophobic
and of course it would be but well join
the club the fact is that as we saw in
the first panel the kind this kind of
personal attack and tarring is going to
be done to anyone who stands up honestly
and deals with these issues but if we
don't more people are going to die and
so it's a matter of are we willing to
stand up and take some heat or are we
going to consign these people to their
fate and I hope as the United States of
America that has always been the Bastion
of Freedom we will take the latter path
thank you